mm go and rest manage and welcome back
to some more Deadpool we're gonna find
out at some backstory on boulevards tell
me about this he's got these awesome
adamantium claws that cut through
anything including my body when I piss
it off guess we're not gonna piss him
off then too bad it's [ __ ] bad
through that pipe what about the ladies
are they dead hello are you see yes they
just [ __ ] die what is it what is with
female characters in this game just
[ __ ] dying or you know that is [ __ ]
up seriously the other girl leaves it
Ram you thought it's gonna be like a
boss battle of whatever sure oh you can
see how they could destroy this entire
island populated with powerful mutants
oh really
here comes Sinister's lackeys some dudes
are blackbirds a landing wasn't exactly
what the [ __ ] is this combo whoa what is
that what does it stock what's going on
how many bad guys are they okay sorry
sorry I didn't mean to do it okay I'm up
look at that fatty that's that's nothing
how you want shuttle you like shotgun
hey calm down
are you pregnant you picked the wrong
time to get tough tons of fun and some
more dudes geez how many [ __ ] dudes
are they going here whatever got me
anyway yeah like a lot of Genosha I'm
pretty sure it's some kind of timeshare
for mutants probably the site of one of
the worst mutant massacres in history
yeah I'm sticking with type [ __ ] okay
get up there Deadpool thank you geez
it's like you don't even love me an
email hey a pie I love pipes it's like
my favorite is I look more people that
want us dead why
thank this
Gerry welcome no I am baby
[ __ ] you had a shotgun is awesome Oh
what's going on another bad guy huh who
the [ __ ] is cable press spacebar okay
who the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] dad
okay good backstory right there I
learned so much from
I like the recaps they're [ __ ]
awesome run in the comics together I
love reunions well I need you to listen
closely
I've time traveled from the future to
bring you a dire warning about my god
here he goes again ten seconds with his
dire warning from the future crap no
it's not confusing I doubt the x-men I
broadcast we may want to pay attention
this good explain a critical plot the
survival of Earth entirely depends on
which all hinges on you Wade now here's
the critical pub nectar to go by cry I'm
sorry I can't do it
alright it may be something important it
looks like cute shouldn't we make it
stop rez okay mate seriously
oh man did that hurt so we give cable
the slip looks lucky left a note huh
what does it say idiot meet me at the
northern end of the shooter was cable to
give us orders in our game oh you'll
miss me incredibly large rusted naked
wanna be your biggest oh don't fall for
that
yeah this is nice make it worth the risk
I mean it is worse there is find your
totally real fangirl [ __ ] yeah I'm just
gonna grab my totally real
come on yeah hello how you guys doing
and they explode on never okay here we
go
[ __ ] yeah what do we do now I'm out of
ideas
okay gotcha gotcha mailing it's my first
date with a bang should we do Italian
Italian Italian why that does no it's
Holly what are you talking about
italiano is the romantic children under
Fame that fool Mexican fairy blue you
will probably poop your pants always do
you like keep hitting them while their
dad
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] many of them okay let's
see we can actually max out the bag the
shotgun damage which does [ __ ] insane
damage
part of your action five weatherman
weather theme what I like the music it's
pretty chill to keep him be it on him
there we go [ __ ] annoying as hell man
geez the lock-on feature does not work
on insert Power Cell okay cool I haven't
and that's some things you're gonna make
a joke about us putting our thing in
that thing that's too easy too easy Yeah
right
it's coming what is this left arrow
okay what's the sound of one robotic arm
clapping step hahaha
I guess make sense that whole is pride
jumping material I think they call that
a glory hole
and that just nasty that is this nice
thing what is this Oh sneak a time I
[ __ ] love how he sneaks come on that
pole you can do this make me proud
and how you doing there sir okay oh geez
come on
nobody [ __ ] give me the killer I love
fine go where are they if this is not a
fangirl I gotta be so disappointed the
one and only sir hey the one and only
costume okay well I guess we [ __ ]
creepy area I don't understand why would
a fangirl be in a place like this it
doesn't make any sense
oh well as long as she has big boobs
nothing I didn't say anything okay let's
go down inside way oh my god it's all
right [ __ ] yeah
oh oh oh what that press Q to squeeze
well [ __ ] why not ah all right ask
what that was about
I don't want to know time is short
guess that bullies and drugs and those
old civil across the island worry will
land the real girls someday this is our
game Wade again really ending I was
worried don't even bother with that
security tower sinister is up there
broadcasting is holed up mr. sinister is
up there as in the S hole who killed
that other a-hole who was my contract
one side summers I got me some business
to fit damnit wait stop
we don't have time to mess with the
security towers oh we do we do
oh we do hello goodbye oh [ __ ] that's a
painful way to go huh more self
we're not even stop thinking what the
[ __ ]
goodbye oh I bet if you google that you
can find some serious [ __ ] so we just
need to [ __ ] clear all the guards
yeah well they know I love you guys
that's awesome
there you go presents for everyone
are you doing it's about time to join
the party summers you've drawn the
attention of every gonna be in the area
that's how we roll we could use a window
it don't run away
let's do it again yeah I need to return
to the future and finish fighting a
battle that you pulled me away from my
corner so we can form a plan of course
they will Wayne of course why would we
wait but we could just finish the game
right now yeah let's go kicks ass before
he gets back
where's the tower engine okay why not oh
okay here we on break open know what we
do with this we should open it we love
insanity we could win up bill billion
dollars holy [ __ ]
magnetic apart-er and in the arms back
in good
that fool never gets what he wants
poor guy I think we [ __ ] up keep us
from that douche nozzle sinister nobody
takes our contract where the hell are we
Oh ma'am Oh
Oh okay I'm gonna jump on these gotcha
well these platforms don't feel very
stable your mom doesn't feel very stable
ma'am
but it's really really okay let's go is
that it
all right time to make my own luck
billion-dollar here we come god damn
cows try wheel there are no cows on
Genosha Oh what the hell well can we
ride the cow please almost there go kill
so let's get to it
yeah okay Oh third time's the charm
enough is enough ah now
Oh
I won those it's not another cow [ __ ]
this storm is really picking up now
that's fine no big deal
there we go all right come on time to
pay the Pinewood the hell happened to
you
are you in the matrix that looks very
uncomfortable and you me you repulsive
putrid mutate destroying this tower will
do nothing to stop my plans to instill
genetic affection upon this world okay
you do will stop my master plan wait
wait are you stuck in there no would be
ridiculous oh so then you would mind if
I played with this what are they gonna
do what you do it no don't touch that I
don't know about you oh [ __ ] bang bang
bang bang bang being a bull
darn good time by the plane my eyebrows
I'm gonna have to end this episode here
but I hope you enjoyed watching leave a
like if your data helps me out a lot hit
subscribe to become a red today and I'll
see you in the next one
you know busy